[Musique]
c'est parti à lui seul il a fait
basculer le match hier lorsqu'il inscrit
son sixième essai sous le maillot
tricolore christophe dominici redonne
l'avantagé à la france et d'un coup d'un
seul
son opportunisme génial le fait entrer
dans la légende du ballon ovale à
solliès-pont dans le var c'est tout le
clan dominici qui s'est enflammé pour
moi c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
je souhaite qu'une que ça arrive à tous
les pères qu'un des enfants qu'ils
soient tous à tous les niveaux sportif
quoi de vivre ce qu'on vit ces fabuleux
parce que je pensais pas que ça puisse
apporter nos joueurs commencent à corps
le rêve de christophe a d'abord débuté
ici sur la pelouse de laval est au début
des années 90 roger di piazza le
président de ce club qui évolue alors en
division 2 se souvient du phénomène
dominici arrivé dans son club à 18 ans
tout feu tout flamme
c'était quelqu'un qui était qu'on ne
pouvait pas me permet de nous au
moulleau quoi c'était il était capable
de n'importe quoi hôtel sur le terrain
qu'en dehors du terrain est pire
j'aime pas c'est tout un tas de trucs
mais bonne sur le terrain'' y est c'est
quelqu'un qui était capable on aime
porter canin stand de faire la
différence et de dix matches l'équipe de
france va faire de toi forden du match -
après deux saisons à laval est
christophe dominici enfile le maillot
toulonnais rct il apprend son métier
peaufine sa technique sans rien perdre
de sa fougue transféré il ya deux ans au
stade français le varois traverse une
période de doute il se blesse à l'épaule
se démotivent jusqu'à ce que cet homme
pierre cesano kinésiologue le remettre
sur pied bien dans ses crampons et dans
sa flèche de particules c'est comme une
formule 1 qui est toute prête qui est
tout dans les plaines pleine possession
de ses moyens mais qui à quelques brides
par ci par là qui l'empêchent de
s'exprimer
moi je suis un régleur de dernier moment
je viens et je fais la maligne la
dernière une mise au point qui lui
permet de s'exprimer de pouvoir
s'exprimer tel qu'il est ce que pierre
ses anneaux lui a appris c'est à
conserver son identité face à tana umaga
le vis-à-vis blague de christophe lebas
roy a su rester lui même joué languit
face au rocher néo zélandais lui qui
avec son mètre 72 a su défier le colosse
maori et ainsi prouver qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire d'être un géant pour être
grand
[Musique]